what is this going on youtube this is
it's like a blog
yo make sure you subscribe right now
turn the post notifications on i got you
what's up youtube come on do it right
now is this the beginning of the video
turn turn then post notifications on
like it drop a comment share it yeah
let's go for the algorithm comment for
the algorithm you guys know what to do
[Music]
here is a sneak peek at the new
thick boy studios it's been a long time
it should be done in a week and you'll
see it's you know it's getting there
with the artists in there we're kind of
game playing stuff
out you'll see still's a ways to go but
you get the idea
i don't have keys yet at the studio it's
not officially my until sunday
sorry we'll be quick
so you walk in big stick boy thing there
we'll be the new find the kit set
done this weekend
the walls are all black so the artist
hey it looks dope but b
it's easier for the artist when they
paint do all their things otherwise
[Applause]
are you brandon yeah oh yeah who's the
next person you're going to be
interviewing
uh brandon moreno oh yeah
no way but yeah he really won the ufc
yeah that was crazy when i opened the
door i was like
is that really him i was like there's no
way that's you good to see you man
thanks for your work
a lot of work to do
put some we don't forget to see so you
look right now it looks like [ __ ] right
side tent's gonna go i thought you see
it all sticking spans right there
that's the goal one week later
what's going on boys
how did you know we'd be here
you just you just worry about yourself
you just worry about your sandwich
some grains dog just got done lifting my
grains this is a keto sandwich
they got keto bread now all keto all the
time
how long do you
i woke up feeling sick had an energy
drink [ __ ] power through it pop some
tylenol
always show up you know what i'm saying
what sets marcus aside from you guys you
guys would have stayed in bed
yeah exactly but you know what if i'm
going to die
at least i'll die in the gym it's like a
good 3 15.
[Music]
husband to a murdered wife i'll have my
vengeance
in this life of the next the spot i'm
standing in right now it's this open
area
this is the priority right now because
the first calabasas
fc fight companion show will be
live july 10th for conor mcgregor dustin
poirier usa 264
me special guest i cannot wait but
you're seeing the spot right now
we got about we have 14 days ish
get some work to do man in here is well
you will find
fighter and the kids planet kid will go
here look at this look at this space
look at this face look at the space look
at somebody's old school phone ring look
at this space though
we got a lot of work to do but we're
getting it done
we're getting it done we hear you guys
we get the concern with the 100 000
subscriber giveaway
we're gonna fly you and a friend out to
work out with me
mark the body harley and backflip lacy
100k is a long ways away and for those
of you that have been riding with us
from the start it's not fair
so we switched it up when do we
pick a winner at 25k subscribers which
we're at 20 now so that should be any
week now
so every 25 we're going to pick one fan
flat la work out with me and the boys at
zoo culture
and sit in on a podcast with a spinal
kid
keenan sting below the belt food truck
calabasas fight companion you picked
it's your choice
so every 25 some someone get flown out
here
so we need 25k we'll pick
50 75 hundo 125
150 so on every 25k
subscribers to the thick boy youtube
we're flying you out
so let's get it we're almost at 20 now
we're at 20. soon we get 25